there's a lot of stuff we do that the
average viewer may not know about so for
the sake of the newer fans we thought
some stuff was worth mentioning the
first rule of Fight Club is you do not
talk about Fight Club first and perhaps
most importantly introducing the
cinemasins patreon
please note everything you enjoy about
our content today will continue to be
freely published for your enjoyment to
cinemasins videos per week to music
video sins per week and a TV sins video
per week and also a deep dive podcast
every week that all continues and
remains free but if you would enjoy
early access to some of that content or
access to live video broadcast from the
podcasting studio head over to our brand
new patreon page and see if you'd like
to join up we're keeping it simple with
3 levels of patronage and reward though
I can tell you that in the spring of
2019 we're going to do something very
cool and big that I think folks will
want to be patrons to experience we have
a podcast called the sin cast available
on iTunes SoundCloud Spotify stitcher
Pandora and other podcasting platforms
we say things like Kermit the Frog
because he is a frog yeah has a cloaca
[Music]
[Laughter]
by definition as a frog we recently
launched TV sins the most requested
anything we've ever had
Game of Thrones Walking Dead we're
sending your favorite shows so subscribe
to stay in the loop you had me at hello
we have a music video since channel
doing the same kind of thing we do to
movies and TV shows two music videos
although it's often a bit more pervy
okay a lot more perfect music videos be
crazy yo that's all you had to say we
have a Twitter well really Jeremy does
that's me I often post pictures of my
cat but I also post links to videos
podcasts and updates on the channel in
general also on Twitter Barrett
Jerr podcast host and boss of music
video sins and writer for all things sin
and chief operating officer of
cinemasins LLC aron Dicer sins writer
podcast guest and TV sins showrunner
number one
jonathan watkins sins writer for all
three channels podcast guest and TV sins
showrunner number two do you think we
need one more we also have merch shirts
hoodies coffee mugs overpriced trucker
hats we don't talk about it a lot or
hammer you over the head with merch
mentions every video but we do have a
district lion shop with a nice variety
of cinemasins gear i make this look good
we have a subreddit with now over 15,000
subscribers regularly discussing our
content and movies in general economy
i've cut it i realize on tangibility we
have a kick-ass website where you can
watch the latest videos binge on videos
by genre and listen to and comment on
our podcast what are you doing here
there's a dance I'm looking a porn our
podcast has a Facebook where Chris
himself responds to questions and
comments and unless you're being a rude
jerk so we don't wondering just where
the air lies in that and that's just
about everything we do that you may or
in out I've already known about